it is the home of model and sturgeon
until last week Scotland's political
power couple now the epicenter of a
police probe
the occupants were out and the
detectives were in Peter model the man
who was the smp's chief executive for
decades was in custody for 12 hours
questioned before being released over
the party's fundraising and finances
this the first big test for the new
first Minister Hamza Yusuf I was told
this morning after the event
um and of course my reaction as you'd
imagine much like anybody involved in
the SMP is that this is a difficulty for
the party but again I've just reiterate
and emphasized it's so important for me
not to comment on a live police
investigation and see and be seen to
Prejudice that in any way shape or form
this is the snp's Edinburgh headquarters
also at the heart of this investigation
police posing questions about 600 000
pounds raised for a second referendum
campaign
this is an extraordinary moment an
embarrassing episode for a party known
for its discipline the question is will
this probe overshadow Nicholas
sturgeon's Legacy after more than 3 000
days in the highest office and will she
too face questions about what she did or
did not know I mean I led the SNP for a
long time so I'm very sad about what's
happening to it and they did about what
it's become but uh who should remember
the cause of Independence and the case
for it has never been stronger and
that's what myself and Oliver
concentrating on putting forward
here Nicholas sturgeon questioned in one
of her last interviews as first Minister
but that's a suggestion you and your
husband will be interviewed have you
heard anything on that but no but I am
not going to comment on I wouldn't
comment on any ongoing police
investigation and I'm not going to
comment on this one
have you been questioned two on the day
she resigned and
a statement saying she had no knowledge
of police Scotland's actions or
intentions and she will fully cooperate
if required but this is the couple's
Back Garden police bagging evidence amid
a two-year investigation culminating in
the arrest of a man once in charge of
Scotland's biggest political party